Now it's time to put together the background
technology that I introduced to you, plus some
more, and describe to you a particular distributor
file system called XFS which is also built at
UC Berkeley. XFS builds on the shoulders of
periodic technologies. The first one, the log based
striping that I just mentioned to you from
the Zebra file system. And another technology called co-operative
cashing which is also a prior UC Berkley project. And in addition to these two
technologies, XFS also has introduced several new nuances in order to make
the distributor file system truly scalable and
get towards what is called serverlessness, or
in other words, no reliance on a
central server. And those techniques include dynamic
management of data and metadata. Subsetting of
the storage servers, and we'll talk about
all of these techniques in much more detail in the rest of this lecture.